In this lecture, we develop the
weak law of large numbers.
Loosely speaking, the weak law
of large numbers says that if
we have a sequence of
independent random variables
with the same distribution,
then the average of these
random variables, which is
called the sample mean,
approaches the expected value
of the distribution.
In this sense, it reinforces
our interpretation of the
expected value as some kind
of overall average.
The weak law of large
numbers is the
reason why polling works.
By asking many people about the
value of some attribute,
and by taking the average of
the responses, we can get a
good estimate of the average
over the entire population.
On the mathematical side, in
order to derive the weak law
of large numbers, we will first
need to develop some
inequalities, namely the
Markov and Chebyshev
inequalities.
Both of them tell us something
about tail probabilities.
Suppose that a is a number.
Then it is reasonable to expect
that the probability
that the random variable exceeds
a will be small when a
is very large.
But how small?
The Markov and Chebyshev
inequalities give us some
answers to this question, based
only on knowledge of the
mean and the variance
of the distribution.
Finally, we will have to deal
with a technical issue.
The weak law of large numbers
talks about the convergence of
a random variable to a number.
For this to make sense, we need
to define an appropriate
notion of convergence.
We will introduce one such
notion that goes under the
name of convergence
in probability.
And we will see that in many
respects, it is similar to the
common notion of convergence
of numbers.